Hey all right Neil what do the recent
reports that the universe is expanding
at a rate 9% faster than we thought
mean for life on Earth nothing right you
mean I've been appointed next Tuesday
I'm safe that solves no earthly problems
other than to reflect on the fact that
our several pounds of gray matter in our
brain has the power to even figure that
out what when will it mean something how
many how many billions yes that's a
great question we don't know and we
didn't know what studying the atom and
molecules in the 1920s would have any
effect on our future at all you can't
even see atoms 50 years later it is the
foundation of the IT revolution
knowledge and understanding of the atom
it's quantum physics so never stand a
denial of what something that whose
value to society we have no clue what it
can be might ultimately become half a
century later right
I'm just saying right I mean especially
about the human body we don't know [ __ ]
about that right or especially deep in
mind I read recently an article that
said we don't know how much water is
appropriate to drink really we don't
even know how much [ __ ] water we
should drink Nick is there a still a
place for me is there still a place for
labor unions in America oh well
absolutely I mean you know look all all
economics is is how humans how human
beings decide who gets what and why and
in the absence of a way for ordinary
people to have power a few of us are
going to get everything and everybody
else is going to get nothing and labor
unions for all their imperfections are
the only way we have ever found to
balance the power of ordinary people and
and and owners and so with you know we
have to find a way to make it work all
right that's coming a long way back yeah
I mean the percentage of workers who are
in unions know for sure and there's all
sort of in persistence yeah yeah there
are all sorts of reasons why the labor
movement has unwound and it is certainly
true that we're never going to go back
to you know how it was so we have a you
know we have a big we have a big bunch
of work to do to reimagine how you know
labor constructs will work in a 21st
century economy you have the you have
the gig economy $10.99 economy we need a
whole new labor construct to allow I
mean what we have to do is find a way to
make make all of the benefits that go
into making somebody a middle-class
person Universal portable and pro-rated
me replied not univer no yeah
Earthwise here's why that nuts thing I
mean government has Roland strengthen
the middle class right our country is as
strong as our middle class and they've
been getting screwed for decades but the
problem is if unions for example need to
also as they recalibrate figure out why
they fell out of favor in the first
place you know what went wrong in the
mid 20th century what went wrong in
social democracies in Europe in the
nineteen seventies because you got to
learn from those but yeah well and there
were a lot of mistakes made this may be
ignorant but isn't it just that the jobs
that people have are changing like what
like people in advertising people in
writing like a lot of the new social
media jobs like there's no unions
that right I know a lot of young people
being taken advantage like writing news
posts for fifty dollars on some of these
but but but there's a reason why there
are four that it has to do with power
and that has to do with the ability to
organize right I mean look fast-food
workers don't have unions yeah and and
look there's no difference between the
amount of value of fast-food worker
creates today and a manufacturing worker
did 40 years ago the difference is the
reason fast-food workers are poor and
and the folks working in factories forty
years ago weren't is power right they
had a union to represent them they don't
create less value the companies aren't
smaller they're not less profitable it
has everything to do with power
Amazon Universe hell no oh hey do you
have you ever belonged to a union have
you been a union news payer yeah no well
I've have companies that have been
unionized but I've never personally been
in one I mean I think that's right after
you busted a lot of our conversation
ever busbar the conversations about
unions are kind of mythical I mean a lot
of people who have it for sure have
never never purchased and wouldn't even
imagine their own workplace nothing AG
for this show that's right a sag I'm off
I'm sag yeah it's a very complicated
problem Matt what is the likelihood that
an alternative third party candidate
emerges as a real possibility in this
election it's it's as likely as it as it
has been certainly since Ralph Nader in
2000 and it's a Black Swan year in so
many different ways and you won't lose
money by betting against third parties
in America that's always been the rule
but we've never seen unfavorability
ratings this high of to major party
candidates people kind of hate them both
within their own political treasure
democrats and republicans do and the
libertarian party which is the only
party that's going to be on all 50
ballots that's not the one of the major
two they've never pulled this high at
this point they always more high early
and they're going well because they have
two Republican former blue state
governors who got reelected which is
exactly the kind of Republican that the
GOP currently is rejected and and if
they get 15% they get in the debates and
the duopoly keeps trying to keep out
more choices from our elections and they
really better stop getting in that way
because the number of independence has
doubled in the last 25 years the party's
a flat line that
people sending a message about
dissatisfaction and dysfunction I think
that there's a lesson here that if you
really analyze it what if you step back
and analyze it I think Trump is in fact
the third party candidate he like he
might be breaking up the Republican
Party exactly if he's running as a
Republican and hardly any Republican
supports him he's a third party
candidate yeah so he's what happens but
when you rise up looking like you're not
you're part of the establishment but
you're not and then he appeals now you
have people voting for what would have
been a third party candidate that
wouldn't have because they would fear
that the third party county wouldn't get
away he kind of ratos enforce the
Republican Party yeah I mean which
Bernie Sanders would love to do in his
own way in the Democratic Party Sanders
is not a Democrat right he's he's a
legitimate challenge to existing
Democratic party structure making the
race a hell of a lot more interesting as
a result it could be that in our hearts
were a four party country yeah it's been
having two parties yeah I actually the
real divisions in politics are not
liberal conservative I think that's
actually and they used to think this way
its radicals reactionaries and reformers
you get people on the far right you get
people on the far left and you get
people in the center who want evolution
not revolution I think that's a much
saner way to think about it but two
kinds of voters all choice informed and
under inform that two-party system
that's good to know like that path lies
a lot of liberal condescension yeah
right to say that the pan liberals are
often uninformed as well yeah absolutely
I give us from their Facebook I didn't
attach one word tonight nobody really I
know I know he just don't I know but you
two didn't you know kind of earlier when
you're talking about Trump voters that
we need to educate them that if you
don't like Trump it means you don't like
the people voting for Trump that's all I
said
and so if you don't like it because you
think they should think about data
differently than you need to educate but
we need to separate out the supporting
event a Trump no but look the Republican
Party has brought this on themselves
right the Republican Party is cracking
up because it has been it has been a
coalition between two basically two
groups of people a tiny number of urban
economic elites and a giant number of
mostly rural
social conservatives right and what
happened over 30 years
is the robot public and party massively
over delivered to that tiny group of
urban economic elites or well while
exporting the jobs suppressing the wages
and destroying the lives of the 99
percent of their of their of their party
the April upside down with his app thing
about free but going in starting a trade
war no no but well I would ever even
consider that that was it exactly but he
called the question on our own economics
he called the question on economics and
the thing is is if you you are part of
the 99% of a Republican Party you have
been economically savaged and the
Republican Party that was supposed to
deliver everything on all these social
issues that you care about whether it's
abortion or gay rights or whatever it is
they delivered nothing nothing
because we won on all those issues right
but to his point they did it by fooling
people yeah absolutely Joe the Plumber
is a great example Joe the Plumber
did not have any money did not have a
plumber's license but was very angry at
Obama because Obama was fixing to raise
taxes is one of the beating you made
over Twitter $20,000 a year
the biggest con john said that was where
he was going right the bigger the con
job it is also the politics of economic
and cultural resentment right and this
is the problem when our politics end up
being our political identities become
end up being very little than the
collection of our grievances and when we
start focusing on hating the other guy
what we're against rather than what were
for and then you get these massive con
jobs pulled by politicians like Donald
Trump and other folks who end up trying
to stoke anger and fear and resentment
in the absence of any positive ideas the
through out way lies but and there's
this other very the reason that economic
inequality is so important is that is
that look here's the thing
prosperity won't eliminate racism but it
is one hell of a distraction right it is
alway hell of a distraction yeah and
when people are feeling like there's a
future line you're doing well right when
they when there's hope for their
children they have a lot less energy for
hating on people that don't look like
him or her different different than the
minorities well I would have to infer
yes right why we have to fix this
problem
final question Neil deGrasse Tyson
this guy's going to be a politician what
what is the greatest natural threat to
humanity that we can do absolutely
nothing about an asteroid a supervolcano
uh so yeah it'd definitely be a
supervolcano because an asteroid we have
the power and the knowledge and the
engineering wisdom to deflect a national
crew swell isn't that thing yeah yeah
exactly that way that's they go on oh
that's that's their that's the let's
blow the sucker out of the sky
approach and in America every time in
America I've said it's what we're really
good at blowing stuff up and that's good
at knowing where the pieces fall right
and we're done
yeah so the kinder gentler solution is
in comes the asteroid and you deflect it
from its intended path and then it rises
earth entirely there's still there to
harm you in another day but if you have
that power you can just keep doing that
and it'll be like a deflection machines
are we funding that adequate what no at
all not at all this tactic no no
depositors iike the early death itself
was deflected a little right when it was
being formed uh well didn't cosmos yeah
no no so what you saw was an asteroid
that was deflected that would later
become the asteroid they took out the
dinosaurs
that's what you saw you mixed up yeah
sorry that's right that's right it's
understandable it's okay so so it's fine
now a lot of implement where we can fit
it now I'm gonna get a B so but a
supervolcano is really bad we have the
knowledge and power because we have a
space program to solve it even though
there's no funded program to deflect
such an asteroid but we know how
intellectually we have no frickin idea
what to do if earth gurgles up and sends
a supervolcano kiss you're asking big is
it okay oh I don't have the power we
don't we don't we don't have it we just
choke us right we don't have the power
of lock-out engineering right to stop a
volcano and it would block out the Sun
it would it would it would kill us all
ten different ways have a great week